I mean I was brought up by a monk and a
nun a not very good Monk and ananas you
can you can see by the fact that I'm
here
and I wholly believed I wholly believed
that the Roman Empire had been a
terrible place and that Christianity had
come and it had blessed it with goodness
and the idea that is goodness
and
if you look at the history it just
doesn't seem to be true it's not as
though the Romans were until they heard
the Ten Commandments going random
planting swords in each other it's they
might have been committing a bit more
adultery but there is almost no evidence
to show that people were worse before
Christianity or better after it and in
fact I would say if you want to
understand the danger of religion and I
see it as a genuine danger as well as
many good things I mean what you have to
look at is not the writings of Saint
Augustine the book you want to look at
is the theodosian code and that was the
law that was the collection of laws that
was made at the end of the century in
which Christianity took control
and for the most of it what it did was
it reinforced Roman laws yes you measure
grain with this yes you sell your cows
like that you own your land if this
happens you can do this that and the
other with your wife and chastise her in
these ways but the book that matters is
the book that they put at the end and
they were the book that was the book
that dealt with the people who the
church who were the stated enemies the
bitter enemies of the church and they
were the Jews the Heretics and the
pagans
and it treated them in terms that were
not just hostile they were sub-human
they were demons they were less than
human they were suffering from a
sickness and they had to be cured and
inverted compass and we know how you
cure Heretics
[Music]
[Applause]
so
I suppose everybody can guess
[Laughter]
no I don't know very very well and I
appreciate I appreciate your insights he
just that in any in any developmental
system
when you focus on one stage
the other side may appear to be
contradicting for the previous state has
been
and that's that's that's about anything
that develops
and you attend between the Old Testament
and the New Testament either you read
something you know formulate the Old
Testament and gets changed in the New
Testament it's just a mutation for for
for a system of belief that that grows
and that develops there's a great deal
in
pre-institutional Christianity that is
enormously respectful of pagan and
culture Pagan persons uh the idea of you
know the obligation one has to to Legal
structures that were Roman at the time
and so on very clear and sometimes
problematic but nevertheless very
respectful of a sort of important
knowledge of justice and so on that it
was present in the Pagan world and if
you look at almost any classic
Theologian they quote Seneca and you
know they quote important classical
writers very freely very respectfully
the the uh the idea I mean obviously
something very Savage took place while
the institution of the church was
forming itself as an institution but
there's nothing in the literature of
Christianity that makes that either
acceptable or necessary you know it's
simply something that happened in the
way things happen in history it said
that ancient Rome
applied the word dignitas
to military empress and conquerors who
returned Victorias from Battle
and their Victory is supposed to have
proven their dignitas their worth their
dignity
and he took the same Christian writers
who according to you destroyed
everything in Rome or the Pagan world to
to have turned this you know so
Christian writers took this expression
and instead of refer to this sense of
Victory and Valor and all of that turn
it turn it on its head on he said and
then said it affects the fact that every
human being is created in the image and
likeness of God this is particularly uh
important I think for some of us from
our society where Christianity has
intruded not all always in very positive
ethical ways
included for the sole purpose very often
are preparing the way it kind of have
all God for the real Stormtroopers of
Commerce imperialism colonialism
exploitation
disdain racial disdain
etc etc and the history of Christianity
in our society as you know uh that's not
being of the best even till today
uh one very important example culturally
when the Christians came
determined to spread the gospel
and they looked around they couldn't
find they needed the devil
I liked later on I'd like to talk about
my experience with the Devil by the way
I think three encounters vicariously but
very interesting but I don't want to uh
I want to attend something when they
came we couldn't find the equivalent
of the devil of Satan and so they took
one of the deities the Yoruba deities
issue
who happens to be a trickster you know a
very complex but alcohol issue the
mastered electrician the electrician and
they took because he's unpredictable and
he he can upset the best late plans you
know Mice and Men and they took his shoe
and decided that is the devil and they
distorted the entire ethical structure
that was based on the Yoruba Pantheon
the virus deities the burials
Departments of existence phenomena
conduct relationship on which a whole
you know functioning ethical structure
I've been built and so when we're
talking about rebuilding creatively
rebuilding uh the our sense of you know
ethical conduct among communities and
then we may have to go all the way back
to what Christianity did to us on the
African continent
that's exciting
now because you know I just happened to
come from
who are two countries west of Nigeria so
I'm from Ghana
and so probably you can talk also about
the experience of Christianity in Ghana
uh certainly certainly the arrival of uh
early Christians from Europe in Ghana
was kind of ambivalent or ambiguous and
it's in his character
some came as pure
missionaries just to talk about the
gospel
some also came as chaplains of of the
color you know colonizing power
and and so you have both of them those
who came as chaplains you know give the
impression that they were related with
Colonial colonization implantation of
other cultures and all but there are
also some who came just
you know for religious religious
purposes